all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show we've known him best for playing
the role of Superman and the DC extended
universe as well as the Man From UNCLE
blood creeks another one of his films
and the latest one that is out in
theaters near you coming out this
weekend is the latest Mission Impossible
fallout Henry Cavill good to see you sir
good to see you
I saw the film I saw it this past
weekend it is one of those where you sit
down and then afterwards you feel like
you've gone through some sort of
cardiovascular experience and and you're
spat right back out and that was awesome
it really is a it's excellent so
congrats in advance Oh No thank you very
much what was it like shooting this
thing for you it was enormous fun but
very grueling as I was saying onset
towards the end of it where is this it's
the the best hardest job I've ever done
and it was it really was extraordinary
fun doing all that my own stunts to a
point I want to know what that point is
actually and that was that's my biggest
heartbreak of the whole movie as well
but I had working with Tom Cruise work
with Chris McQuarrie working with that
until I cast was a genuine pleasure and
I I count my lucky stars every day I
think about it
but it was very very uncomfortable now
you're playing a CIA agent in this film
who is in a way teamed up with the the
Tom Cruise IMF team but also sort of
keeping an eye on him and in this film
we just saw for the television of 4ad
audits for the TV audits we just saw you
destroying a men's room in a fight scene
with Tom Cruise in another character
that you said took four weeks to shoot a
four week fight scene in a men's room
yes and was that the one where Tom
Cruise reportedly broke his ankle No why
don't you Tom for part of that shoot
because we came back to that we shot it
for yes I think two and a half weeks
three weeks and then we came back to it
to finish some bits later in the
production yes it was later in the
production when we came back that he had
a broken ankle and he was doing a lot of
that stuff with a broken ankle
it's amazing what he could do i he was
told when he broke his ankle that it was
going to be a something silly like six
month
recovery and then he may never run again
he was sprinting on it within seven
weeks come on now yeah no seriously
experiencing on it full sprint like Tom
Cruise sprint cuz there is one Cena I
want to give away too much what but you
know as one seen the movie where it
looks like because he is kind of chasing
running throughout the entire city of
London yep you know and I just came back
from London with my whole family and
he's a sightseeing tour and I was in a
car and I was exhausted by the end of
that day it seemed like you saw the
entire city he was running was it app
was that that's running yes right after
part of that was part of that was broken
part of that wasn't broken
that's unbelievable and you can't tell
the difference he's he's a tough days he
would what do you would you say Tom
Cruise is the best man I would say you
know you think about this you run the
debates Tom Cruise is the greatest movie
runner we have right
it looks better running than anyone else
who's ever run in a movie I can't think
of anyone else apart from that scene in
Chariots of Fire nice pretty cool what
do it
well Danny run once but that was my
favorite part of Mission Impossible fall
out was the Vangelis theme that was
playing behind his run in this film yeah
it was phenomenal scores good yes our
Vangelis did it or not but so how how
fast can you run though Henry uh come on
now let's go I mean if you and Tom
Cruise are running a race can you can
you run him down I don't know I don't
know look but I know if I can outrun Tom
necessarily right and what so what's
your biggest heartbreak you'd mention
basically we have an end yeah we could
actually right here I'm wearing death
shoes this is slippery they look nice
but it's by the way I have if you see
the logo of the show that's me running
in a suit I do that at the NFL Scouting
Combine every year running in a suit
okay running the 40-yard dash and I did
run the first few years in lace-up dress
shoes like that no I'll tell you it
might have been the dumbest decision of
everything yeah you know I could have
really gotten hurt Henry Cavill here on
the Rich Eisen show now you are a fan as
we've seen on your Instagram account of
the Kansas City Chiefs yes sir no you
are most decidedly not from Kansas City
correct not that I know okay now you're
from the island of
yes erect yes just near the coast of
Normandy but you're obviously on the the
UK side yeah yeah it's it's it's
considered a crown Protectorate so part
of the British Isles okay so now how do
you become a Kansas City Chiefs fan
Henry well spend a lot of time in
America learning to enjoy football I
realize how to choose a team and it's
never wise to choose a team based upon
who your partner is because what if you
fall out it's true and it's also good to
have some rivalry in the house anyway
yes and I was trying to think of
something which would always stick and I
figured
Superman's from Kansas I was playing
Superman at the time and it just kind of
made sense to me so if Clark Kent was
born in or jor-el was in Pittsburgh
you'd have been a Steelers fan is that
what we're saying see this is my next
choice obvious reason right
but yes yeah I just figured you know but
that's gonna be somewhere where I feel a
very close connection with that
character sure and therefore a close
connection was very strong that's where
you chose the Kansas City Chiefs from
yep no kidding and so we just showed
photographs of you on the sidelines of
what that their playoff game a couple of
years ago but just to januaries ago
against this the Steelers that night
what was your experience in Arrowhead it
was loud
I like how loud it is there right is
absolutely fantastic we what I found the
biggest thing for me was how much of a
spectacle it was I wasn't expecting to
go down to the sidelines for one I was
expected to sit up in the stands and
watch the game from there and that was
privileged enough but going down there
with the giant flamethrowers and stuff
and yeah that's some exciting stuff yeah
it's like if I imagine it would feel
very similar to be a gladiator in Rome
comparatively speaking well the first
time I went to Arrowhead and I heard
them during the national anthem when
they say instead of a home of the Braves
they substitute Braves with Jesus and it
just came out of everybody's like it's
cool you know yeah everybody's got it
really just took me aside I'm like it's
it's a good stadium to go
okay and this coming season I'm gonna
try and get there as often okay so
you're you would consider yourself a
Chiefs fan that's ah but are you your
rugby individual first would you say yes
okay yeah did you play rugby I as a boy
who played rugby yeah and up until what
eighteen nineteen and then the career
started yes the hardest thing for me
about American football yes was coming
over here and comparing it to rugby
because they're two very different
sports I didn't realize that at the time
I just sorted contact sports and I
thought wait one of them they wear pads
and the other one they don't yes so and
one of them they run more the other one
they don't so which one do I prefer and
I was like definitely the harder one but
American football is more like chess
then rugby is rugby I consider more like
a like a I don't know like a battlefront
it's nonstop moving shifting changing
yeah and it's grueling and American
football is you're moving pieces and
you're making set moves all the time
yes and it's I didn't get that at first
and then when I did get it I learned to
love the game and they're two very
different things the X's and O's and
moving pieces around and yeah everything
is so precise but in rugby it's just
like you're just bashing heads together
I mean you wouldn't I don't know that's
a no - Jessica Dix you don't wearing
helmets so you trying to avoid head bash
cuz you know so many people say that the
way to take head injuries out of
American football is to take the helmets
off them that they would not be bashing
heads if the helmets weren't on thing is
if you take the helmets off you have to
take the pads off it's the hard plastic
which is causing yes like an injury and
so if you then have the head on protect
it's gonna be way worse I mean we've now
gone this far with American football
yeah I I don't think it's if you take it
all away is that gonna take away part of
American football so which is tougher
which is tougher yeah rugby or American
football you know what both have
different levels of toughness I think
there's something about rugby we just
said feels a lot like war it's nonstop
and it is grueling but you see the
injuries which come out of football
right that makes them pretty tough so
which is tougher rugby or filming a
Mission Impossible fan which is tougher
well we have to fill Mission Possible
for a year
you imagine playing rugby for an entire
year I can't believe he's gotta be rugby
it's good good and then again then again
there's less likelihood of death and a
mission impossible there's a high
likelihood of death on a number of
occasions okay 60 seconds we take a
break we're gonna get back I want to
hear a little bit more that would come
back and we also have cold we do this
with a ton of our celebrity guests cold
what the IMDB folks on your your debt
the Internet Movie Database have your as
facts from your life and see what's true
or false oh cool okay that's coming up
with Henry Cavill here on the Rich Eisen
show back in 60 seconds with one of the
stars of Mission Impossible fall out
okay welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Henry Cavill added to the cast of
Mission Possible fallout that brings Tom
Cruise ving rhames Simon Pegg back in
the mix Alec Baldwin is in this film as
well Angela Bassett plays your boss yes
indeed that's a badass boss and yes it
is
don't mess with Bassett that was that
the rule on the set was that the rule in
life it's a rule in life right set yeah
she got her groove back a very long time
ago she's pretty much she's um she's a
cool lady yeah and you play and Alec
Baldwin in this film Michelle Monaghan
who's been on this show that's it really
is just a fun film in which again you
said the last segment doing your own
stunts you suffered heartbreak or
something like that
yeah doing your own stuff well I mean I
when I was given the opportunity to be
on this movie yes I was excited about
doing all my all my own stunts and I
went into McHugh and Wade Eastwood who's
the stunt coordinator and second unit
director and said if it's legal and I
won't end up killing anyone
then I'm in assume I'm saying yes to any
stunt you're designing or building and
they did and they put me in everything
and I knew there was a halo jump in the
movie my brothers were in the Armed
Forces
some of my best friends are all former
military and I was very keen to the
hello jump that was that's my bucket
list kind of thing halo jump out of a
c-17 is where you'll find me smiling and
they wouldn't let me do it and I was I
was begging Tom I was like Tom just just
put me in coach you know I'm here in the
back of a c-17 with you have a parachute
on I've done some Windtunnel time just
let me jump out I'll be good I promise
hmm and he said look Henry I I know what
you're thinking I know how you feel I'm
who says this yeah I would feel exact
same way but if you jump and we do the
sequence in the air without you having
hundreds of hours of training you'll
probably kill everyone and I said I'll
let you off this time Tom because an
item to check off on your bucket list
shouldn't not only bring about your
demise but the one right
it's supposed to be a long list yes
before you actually you know yeah but
that was that was one which which stung
a little bit but it's taught me a lesson
which is I thought my physicality would
be enough to get me through most stunts
you gone to a movie you trained for it
and then you do the stunts it's not the
case
Tom prove that to me on this movie he
spent a year and a half learning how to
fly a helicopter stunt flyer helicopter
in the mountains
he spent hundreds of hours skydiving so
we could shoot that sequence and this
was all done in his own time not on this
movie time and so I'm going away from it
thinking I need to get licenses and all
these kind of things in my own time so I
can take him to the next movie and the
next time there's a halo jump I'm gonna
do it and I'm gonna do better than Tom I
like it that should try to that's your
competitive spirit yeah so maybe we can
combine the two things that we're
talking about Henry okay because
sometimes prior to NFL games there is a
parachutist that comes in and brings the
flag in or bring something maybe you
could do that for a Kansas City Chiefs
game that would guys practice that would
be seriously good I think it's practice
and you want to practice up to that
point and then do that prior to yes I
think the idea of to arrow have actually
parachuting to a stadium isn't that easy
because if you think about it do you
think of the heat coming off a stadium
and when you finally hit that air pocket
what happens to you I think had to be
quite a good jumper yes it takes a lot
of experience right it
I mean maybe one day okay you want to
mess that up like yeah America and then
just fly into the ground just arrived on
the 50-yard line here in our head yeah I
mean Kansas City's home opener let me
give you a date I have it here right in
front of me
Kansas City's home opener is not until
mid-september so oK you've got some time
yeah therefore they're on the road the
first two weeks their first home game is
against the San Francisco 49ers on
September 23rd I know what you're doing
on Sunday September 23rd but maybe you
can get some time and maybe maybe what
about that first their away games their
first away games okay their first away
game the Kansas City Chiefs are at the
right here and taking on the Chargers
huh in Southern California okay
when do they play the Dolphins when do
they play the Dolphins do they play the
Dolphins at all this year Chris can you
look that up why the Dolphins is that
just something you just want to i
sometimes spend some time in florida so
okay I'll go down there and see if it's
geographically sound for you
annoy some people they play the Dolphins
this year Chris can you look that up for
Henry Cavill I'm gonna be hard playing
that heat in the meantime Henry Cavill
here on the show so you play a CIA agent
in this film negative no dolphins
unfortunately no yeah sorry we'll figure
it out maybe get extra time so Henry
Cavill here in the Rich Eisen show you
play a CIA agent in this film The Man
From UNCLE yep you also played an agent
yep I do what about maybe an mi6 agent
without be a lot of fun the numbers 200
is enough yes yes seven after that I
think that would be I'd be a lot of fun
we'll see I mean if the opportunity
comes my way then I will definitely jump
at it but that's up to them not to me
okay what if what can I make the pitch
for you do it I don't want any this is
this is free of charge okay okay
if it works let's just how many send you
some memorabilia from the set well I
will take that okay I will take that
Aston Martin please yes sorry okay it's
it's it's the the broccolis right is
that it's Brooklyn Wilson okay broccoli
and Wilson hey broccoli Wilson we've
never met but I have met Henry Cavill
sitting next to me right here I just
heard how he gets upset when he's not
allowed to jump out of helicopters in
midair he gets upset when he's not
allowed to do his own stunts this man
looks to me and sounds to me like James
freakin bond let's get him in let's get
him is double-oh-seven
what do you think I think it's pretty
good I'm pretty good at should I have
changed anything or um no no that's
that's a good one okay yeah I mean
you've been Superman a bit safe man
I've been CIA agents twice now yes right
right it would be the right thing how do
you take how do you take your martini
I take it mmm there's a correct answer
to this and there's the honest answer
which is shaken not stirred we've got a
couple of Henry Cavill true or false
questions before we let you go okay
right here Henry Cavill here on the
Henry Cavill it is true or false that
you achieved 3% body fat for your role
as Superman is that true or false I
never took a body fat reading but I
don't think those are lows 3% that's
that's super low so that's false that's
false I couldn't even imagine what 3%
would like bodybuilders that's like a
4:1 one performance bodybuilders you
can't hold that maybe you can but I like
probably good but is it true key you
consumed 5,000 calories a day for that
role yes I was when I was building 5,000
calories what in the hell were you
eating at 5,000 calories a day um a lot
I can't remember that was many many
years ago now I was a Man of Steel but a
lot of it in the post-workout shake you
put coconut milk in there and it it
makes everything it's you can fit a
day's worth of calories into one shake
oh so you're not like rolling through
the in-n-out burger or anything like no
unfortunate mean that there is a
methodology which does that but it's so
fat afterwards all right next one for
Henry Cavill true or false that you're a
huge fan of video games and almost
missed being cast as Superman because
you almost missed the phone call
inviting you to do that because you were
too busy playing a video game is that a
true story Hoff true yes I was playing
was Warcraft and the phone rang I didn't
look at it because I was doing something
more important obviously and then I
looked down at the last second and sort
said Zack Snyder and went for the phone
and missed the call but at that stage
that was him calling me to let me know I
had the roll so okay it wasn't like if I
didn't answer the call I don't get okay
there wasn't like a plan B voice max he
didn't want it yeah that's right go get
us some buddy else you're fluent in
French conversational in it
and German and can order a beer and
check true or false I wish I speak a
little bit of French
I see more Italian than French okay but
again just a little bit and a few words
in German and whichever country I go to
we're trying to learn how to order a
beer can you order a beer in Czech
I can't remember how to do it now but
you to use it yeah yeah okay you would
yeah come over right now okay stop my
head well get it ready for the next Bond
film and last one for you right here the
Twilight author Stephenie Meyer wrote
the character of Edward Cullen mm-hm
based on you said a true story I heard
something like that
I don't know if it was based on it maybe
it was based on me when she wrote it but
when it came to the movie being cast
she was definitely very keen on me
playing the role but I was I think I was
too old at that stage to oh that's cruel
something was going on and so I didn't
get it right because the character 17
years old yeah but I was that was I was
in my early 20s then okay well
thankfully it's all worked out very well
for you Henry
so far this movie is great it really is
so much fun and I can't believe that
you're doing things yourself because it
is wild one scene after another after
another you know and it's just a blast
from beginning to end so congrats on
this and don't be a stranger hopefully
you'll be back here again I'll be back
well take I'll take the fact that you
didn't take your jacket off in this
conversation that we're good yeah I mean
I may take it off off camera off to it's
but you did well today thank you thanks
Henry I appreciate that I appreciate
that I'll take it Henry Cavill check
them out along with Tom Cruise and the
rest of the Mission Impossible fallout
cast in theaters near you on the 27th
which is just in tomorrow in a theater
near you the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience